bonjour les pivots jour patrice alors on
va dire qu'il nous aide parce que pour
les gens qui ne vous connaissent pas
encore vous êtes dans l'administration
préfectorale vous êtes sous préfet et
sous préfet de cognac
vous avez été longtemps en prison un
vrai devoir côté des barreaux sylvain 22
ans
vingt deux ans dans l'administration
fédérale est directeur de harrow
directeurs de prisons directeur
d'établissement on appelle ça comme on
veut donc j'ai dirigé des prisons
pendant 22 ans dont la dernière fois ci
la centrale de poissy la centrale de
poissy et c'est votre troisième livre
alors il y avait il y avait un livre
sont revus le taulier l'atelier à chez
fayard qui était sorti en 2010 après
donc je me suis laissé aller à ma petite
passion qui était l'écriture de polars
dont je sois tim pollard l'hôtel est
naufragé est là donc au dessus des
horizons verticaux sorti au mois de
septembre au mois de septembre aux
éditions la joie ni c'est ça qu'on va
parler évidemment aujourd'hui alors
d'abord peut-être est-ce qu est-ce que
cette idée d'écrire des romans policiers
est ce qu'elle vous tient depuis
longtemps est ce que les fonctions que
vous avez peu exercé auparavant vous en
donner des idées pour écrire cette fois
là pour tout dire il ya une mini scène
pendant dix ans il ya une mini scène de
ceux de ceux dans ce roman que j'ai
écrit l'été du bac j'avais 18 ans déjà
donc j'ai déjà jeu
j'adorais écrire des petites nouvelles
je peux d'espionnage qui peut des
nouvelles policières
puis bon après évidemment il ya la vie
est passée par là je suis entre de la
pénitentiaire et puis lorsque
je me suis remis à l'écriture avec cette
fois-ci l'intention de publier parce que
c'est toujours bien de raconter une
histoire mais de la raconter à beaucoup
de monde de la partager
bien je me suis dit en faisant un retour
sur les 22 ans de pénitencier que
j'avais vécu j'avais vraiment de quoi
nourrir la matière et de la matière
alors on va on va parler du livre
évidemment quand on retrouve d'abord ya
des scènes qui se déroulent sur tout et
que c'est très rapidement un des seuls
qui se succèdent et des chapitres est
très court on passe à un autre
très vite on va parler un peu un peu des
personnages ensuite c'est presque très
cinématographique un peu comme écriture
et il ya ça commence quand même
extrêmement violemment fin il ya des
morts il ya toujours avec c'est avec
cette phrase des gens qui se suicident
ou disparaissent qui sont assassinés ne
sait pas très bien et qui disent tous
j'accepte j'accepte le châtiment qui m'a
conduit au dessus des horizons verticaux
et au dessus des horizons verticaux
c'est ce livre dit évidemment très
énigmatique puisque ça veut dire tout de
suite les horizons verticausse est sorti
de sa soeur d'une étude d'un biochimiste
s'est aperçus que souvent après des ce
qu'on appelle les expériences de mort
imminente des ennemis les gens décrivent
le phénomène du tunnel blanc mais
également phénomène de renversement de
des horizons qui deviennent verticaux et
donc par extension l'horizon verticale
c'est la mort alors je disais des
chapitres échos des morts assez violente
ya aussi des scènes de tortures terrible
enfin est-ce que vous avez une
fascination chez vous pour l'être pour
la violence non enfin quand je dis
fascination ça peut être facile à sion
répulsion non en fait j'utilise la
violence pour
comment dire optimisé sublime et presque
le style que j'essaye de pulser sur un
polar qui est d'avoir quelque chose de
très visuel qu'on ne vous disiez tout à
l'heure et de super league mais quoi
c'est surtout ça c'est en fait le les
crimes viennent comme une espèce de
ponctuation dans l'histoire pour que
quand même le lecteur arrive à
s'oxygéner un petit peu dans l'histoire
mais au final soit un petit peu perdu
dans l'histoire ne sache pas finalement
qui est le tueur comment ça peut évoluer
est arrivé au suspense figaro suspense
final aux révélations de la fin du pôle
durement mais quand même il faut les
imaginer alors qu'est ce que je dis
félicitations que je dis ce que je dis
souvent il ya des scènes très très forte
très très dur alors qu'ils sont
formidables car on est c'est vrai qu'on
le quitte pas l'univers quand on a
commencé mon envie évidemment de savoir
alors quand on écrit un polar soit
l'auteur ne ne sait rien et il invente
tout mais ce qui est le cas de deux ans
vous donc voilà d'auteur qui n'ont pas
évolué dans le mille de la police delà
de la criminalistique excellera son cto
ou et beaucoup de choses
et croyez moi on est obligé de se brider
parce que il ya quand même une constante
c'est que à rien n'est aussi horrible
que le crime envahie quoi le crime en
vrai et il est vrai que bon
après 22 ans dans les prisons notamment
je fermais j'irai pas mal de prison avec
des détenus de très très dangereux en
lisant les freins les fréquentes en en
connaissant leur dossier leurs affaires
ça risque effectivement venir épauler
notre imagination donc les scènes dont
vous parlez c'est sympa ça sort pas de
mes idées noires ça sort de deux crimes
commis en vrai dans la réalité que j'ai
mis à la sauce au polar quoi alors il ya
évidemment ça se passe donc dans
plusieurs yeux et on recommence alors
comme aux abords dans le bunker d'hitler
début début et puis après on part à
notre époque à paris pour la saint jean
de luz on va au nicaragua on ira
versailles aussi au maroc au maroc
absolument notamment en prison au maroc
c'est pour ça qu'ils disaient qu'ils
avaient une scène de prison dont
beaucoup de lieux et avec des crimes
alors c'est pas très bien pourquoi ces
gens meurent qu'il est us qui se tuent
eux-mêmes ce qu'ils finissent par se
suicider et puis il ya aussi un flux qui
est très intéressant évolution dans les
zac mc5 butler jacques becker qui comme
souvent abandonnés dans les dons dans
les polars sont des gens qui sont qui
sont aux prises avec leurs propres
démons derrière que will un peu
alcoolique on apprendra qu un drame
d'abord dans une famille sa fille
va être enlevé ce qui est un des
ressorts des livres vous avez un peu
travaillé aussi avec les policiers
évidemment vous avez produit comme ça
beaucoup d beaucoup de flics son
ensemble comme ça si j'avais des maux
internes dont l'âge et jusqu'à 1 pouces
et le tout est assez loin passage très
non c'est vrai que quand on discute
quand je discute avec des avec des
collègues de la police qui au quotidien
fréquentes côtoie la mort la vraie pas
celle qu'on voit là les polars mais la
vraie lame est partenaire de la mère de
famille qui vient de tuer son enfant
levi ses rangs ou ou des braquages qui
mal qui tourne mal
bon c'est vrai que à partir d'un certain
nombre d'années
il peut y avoir une certaine lassitude
est effectivement une fatigue psychique
psychologique et puis effectivement on
voit dans l'actualité tous les jours que
certains collègues de la police
mettre fin à leurs jours c'est un vrai
problème dans la police nationale
parce qu'il ya eu un accès immédiat
larmes de service et puis il ya
effectivement des troubles des troubles
psychologiques qui peuvent être
aggravées par ailleurs par par des
difficultés familiales et mes séries que
si on cumule la fois des problèmes
personnels des problèmes familiaux plus
des choses pas à pas très sympa au
travail ça peut ça peut dégénérer et ses
gains de 2,7 et c'est le cas pour zac
pour zac qui est bon c'est vrai qu'à un
moment enfin est ce que c'est parce que
jamais dans le polar jusqu'où on peut
raconter les choses mais il trouve le
type qui a enlevé sa fille et lui faire
passer un sale moment si je peux me dit
alors c'est vous le raconter c'est aussi
une thématique puis enfin forte d'un
seul un saut polar c'est à dire que ce
soit une criminelle où un flic en
policier jusqu'où voire même nombre
normal hein vous et moi
jusqu'où un second est ce qu'on serait
prêts à aller pour se venger de
quelqu'un que de quelqu'un qui nous a
fait du mal et en l'espèce qui a fait du
mal quelques noms de famille et là c'est
une question que bon qu'on se pose à ce
polar et ont fait plus que se la poser
puisque on a les réponses et c'est ça
qui est ça aussi parce qu'on peut
s'interroger après est ce qu'il ya un
bien et un mal
est ce que est ce qu'il est beau et et
les méchants quelle est votre réponse
pas pour ça parce que même si on voit
bien qu'il ya des assassins d'un côté
des victimes de l'autre même si c'est
des vengeances utilisation du allman
vous êtes posé des questions morales
comme ça on écrit on
donc vous est ce que vous racontez alors
aussi mais une fois il ya deux approches
et la prochaine fois glos saxon où il ya
le bien le mal et les filiales approche
un petit peu plus latine ray ou là c'est
50 nuance de gris coin sans faire de
plus pour 1 mais voilà
et en plus mon passé pénitentiaire me
fait me fait dire que le pire des
criminels le pire des salopards entre
aiguë mais à un moment donné il garde
toujours une part d'humanité quoi donc
c'est ce qui est intéressant de faire ce
mélange d'un policier qui est tourmenté
qui peut aller jusqu'à des pulsions
morbides
mais également un criminel qui a
abandonné garde toujours une part
d'humanité
alors il ya autre chose qui hérite de ce
livre c'est l'apocalypse selon saint
jean et vous retournez pratiquement tous
les tous les chapitres ya une dimension
religieuse se trouvaient dans ce livre
alors il ya rien c'est ça qui va falloir
qu'il ya toujours il ya toujours ce set
ce parallèle avec les des petits
passages de l'apocalypse selon saint
jean que je mets un gène tet2 de passage
qui résume un petit peu la thématique du
paragraphe sait très bien que ray on
parle de loi du talion parle de
vengeance on parle de tout un tas de
deux phénomènes bon celui qui a péri
pack qui pêche par le glaive périra par
le glaive
bon il ya effectivement des renvois la
religion d'autant que à un moment donné
c'est vrai que certains certains
meurtres sont commis pour des raisons
d'intégrisme religieux me reliant le
lieu à une grosse actualité aujourd'hui
je disais tout à l'heure c'est un roman
voilà quand on commence on envie de
tourner les pages d'un prêt de sterna
vous avez des maîtres dans halo en
écriture je ne lis pas de polar avant ça
peut paraître alors je suis un grand fan
de science-fiction est là j'adore les la
série des dunes et ses dépôts large et
j'ai lu quelque 101 antonio est un jeune
parce que mon père était fan un grand
fan de frédéric dard mais je ne lis pas
de polar je suis plus bon je suis plus
de classiques j'adore hemingway est un
mec
zola des trucs un peu mais quand vous
commencez à les créer ouais alors ce cas
oui je sais j'ai commencé à écrire jury
j'écris toujours le prologue et
l'épilogué c'est à dire j'ai le début et
la fin j'ai une trame une espèce de
cordon ombilical entre les deux et après
c'est ça vient au fur et à mesure de
l'écriture et donc les personnages
peuvent vous surprendre de temps en
temps j'essaye de faire en sorte de 800
me surprennent et ça ne surprenne bien
sûr qu'il est sûr c'est ce qui est aussi
intéressant c'est que même moi quand
j'écris je vis une espèce aventure que
j'ai pas de voilà je laisse les choses
se déroulaient il ya bien sûr une
ossature parce qu'il faut toujours
qu'ils ont un plan
il ya aussi un ordre chronologique parce
que notamment quand les policiers vont
ne se déplacent à l'étranger il faut
toujours tenir compte du décalage
horaire pour qu'une certaine crédibilité
mais
ouais c'est une aventure littéraire
c'est alors bon c'est sûr que des fois
enfin marc alain peu qu'un juge écrit un
peu trop tard mais oui parce que vous
avez c'est ça oui il faut préciser que
je n'écris pas au bureau non c'est à
nice et il faut le dire je ne crie pas
je n'écris pas au bureau d'aidé aux
étrangers je passe beaucoup de week end
à écrire ça et beaucoup de nuits aussi
mais mais mais vous l'écrivez pas au
bureau mais non on le peut le lire
partout je vous le conseille vivement sa
peine au dessus des horizons verticaux 7
aux éditions la joie ni d'olivier morel
c'est un excellent polar ce jeudi saint
voilà vous commencez vous pouvez plus
vous êtes obligés de passer des nuits
blanches à cause de vous merci beaucoup
je vais vous remerciez pas prêt